[Música]
hola esto es áfrica siete días del
magazine donde les presentamos la
actualidad del continente africano estos
son los titulares
comenzamos nuestra edición en sudán
donde grupos prodemocráticos anunciaron
la formación de un consejo
revolucionario contra la junta militar
en el poder abordamos también el tema
del aborto y de los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos hacemos un balance de la
situación en áfrica con mala chabot de
la federación internacional de
planificación familiar una ong con sede
en kenia y vamos a colombia donde se
celebrará en septiembre el african sin
festival un evento para generar puentes
entre áfrica y su diáspora
empezamos en sudán donde los grupos
prodemocracia se crearon la semana
pasada un consejo revolucionario para
supervisar las manifestaciones contra la
junta militar los detalles en el
siguiente informe
en sudán o un consejo revolucionario
contra el general abdelfatah albor hunt
fue establecido
los grupos prodemocráticos anunciaron su
creación el 7 de julio tras rechazar la
oferta del líder militar de instaurar un
gobierno civil y la misión del consejo
revolucionario es dirigir la acción
revolucionaria organizando el movimiento
popular las manifestaciones la
desobediencia civil y las huelgas es
también liderar la acción elaborar una
carta política unificada basada en las
propuestas de los comités de resistencia
y otras organizaciones de las fuerzas
revolucionarias
desde el golpe de estado del 25 de
octubre de 2011 114 manifestantes
fallecieron y miles resultaron heridos
mientras que las protestas continúan
exigiendo la renuncia de alborán ese día
el general al burhan propuso dejar que
los civiles formaran un gobierno pero
anunció que los militares seguirían
desempeñando un papel en la política
sudanesa a través de un consejo supremo
de las fuerzas armadas alega la gala
dice que quiere devolver a los militares
a sus cuarteles pero al mismo tiempo
quiere llevar el poder civil a los
cuarteles y esto es una forma de
reforzar su control
ante el estancamiento político los
comités de resistencia punta de lanza de
las protestas decidieron cambiar su
estrategia
además de crear el consejo
revolucionario cada noche varias plazas
de las principales ciudades sudanesas se
transforman en un ágora popular donde se
discute de política y economía en un
país donde la inflación supera el 200
por ciento bajo las banderas de sudán la
multitud asegura que se quedará hasta
que la nación sea dirigida por civiles
se trata de un reto en un país que ha
permanecido bajo el control del ejército
de forma casi ininterrumpida desde la
independencia en
jose eduardo dos santos el ex presidente
de angola que gobernó su país con mano
de hierro durante casi cuatro décadas
murió a los 79 años en el exilio
el exmandatario pasa a la historia por
escándalos de corrupción nepotismo y
abusos contra los derechos humanos
veamos
jose eduardo dos santos ex jefe de
estado de angola falleció el viernes 8
de julio en esta clínica de barcelona en
españa la vida de este hombre está
estrechamente relacionada con el país
que dirigió durante 38 años ya desde
adolescente luchó por la
autodeterminación en el movimiento
popular para la liberación jaakkola en
1975 el país obtuvo su independencia y
agostinho neto fue el primer presidente
de la nación cuando murió en 1979 jose
eduardo dos santos fue nombrado para
sucederle el mandato de los santos como
jefe de estado estuvo marcado por 27
años de guerra civil entre su partido
apoyado por rusia y cuba y la unión
nacional para la independencia total de
angola del líder insurgente jonas
savimbi que contaba con el apoyo militar
de eeuu
cuando la guerra civil terminó en 2002
los santos se presentó como el nombre
que había traído la paz y en los años
siguientes
siguió prometiendo convertir el país en
una potencia continental todo el mundo
debe darse cuenta de que nuestro gran
proyecto es hacer de angola un país
próspero
con instituciones democráticas sólidas y
abierto al futuro
pero hoy el nombre del expresidente se
asocia sobre todo a grandes escándalos
de corrupción y aunque angola es el
segundo productor de petróleo de áfrica
sub-sahariana el país sigue siendo uno
de los más desiguales del mundo en la
gran mayoría de la población vive en la
pobreza extrema la oposición denuncia el
nepotismo de dos santos mientras que
filtraciones periodísticas conocidas
como lunada leaks ha mostrado el alcance
de la corrupción de su familia su hija
isabel dosantos considerada la mujer más
rica de áfrica por la revista forbes
tiene un patrimonio estimado en más de
dos mil millones de dólares
el presidente básicamente privatizó el
estado en favor de su familia y de unos
pocos allegados para estos individuos se
trata de tener los recursos a su
disposición para tener el mismo estilo
de vida que tienen las personas más
ricas del mundo sin importarles lo que
le ocurra al pueblo
la muerte del exdirigente se produce en
un momento especialmente delicado para
el país que se prepara para las
elecciones generales de agosto
cambiamos de tema para abordar ahora la
cuestión del derecho al aborto y de los
derechos sexuales y reproductivos en el
continente
empezamos por algunos datos áfrica tiene
la mayor tasa de embarazos no deseados
en el mundo 91 por cada 1.000 mujeres
frente a la media mundial de 64 por cada
1000 mujeres
de los 54 países africanos túnez
legalizó el aborto en
1973 y 5 otros países de áfrica
subshariana zambia benin cabo verde
santo tomé y príncipe y sudáfrica lo
permiten bajo cualquier caso como
podemos ver en este mapa una gran
mayoría de países aprueba el aborto
cuando la salud de la madre está en
peligro sin embargo como lo vemos aquí
una decena de países no penalizan
incluso en casos de violación o de
incesto
según el guttmacher institute en áfrica
subshariana de los 255 millones de
mujeres en edad fértil el 45% vive en
lugares donde las leyes son muy
restrictivas el 47 por ciento donde las
leyes son moderadamente restrictivas y
el 8% donde el aborto está ampliamente
legal
para hablar de este tema nos acompaña
mal hasta bot de la federación
internacional de planificación familiar
una ong con sede en nairobi la capital
de kenia
málaga gracias por estar con nosotros
cómo calificaría usted el progreso en
términos de acceso seguro al aborto y
más allá del aborto cuál es la situación
en términos de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos en el continente
whiting de áfrica occidente dentro del
continente africano la situación del
aborto varía bastante pero también varía
la situación más amplia relacionada con
la salud y los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos hay países como somalia
donde el aborto es 100% ilegal y otros
como sudáfrica donde es 100% legal
y hay países en el medio por supuesto
donde el aborto es permitido por ejemplo
sólo para proteger la vida de la mujer o
en casos de violación e incesto así que
la cuestión del acceso al aborto en todo
el continente es bastante desigual pero
más allá del aborto no hablamos de salud
y derechos sexuales y reproductivos esto
también se encuentra dentro de un
aspecto muy vasto
pero en general los indicadores de los
derechos sexuales y reproductivos son
muy bajos en el continente especialmente
en áfrica central y occidental la
mortalidad materna sigue siendo alta en
estas regiones en cuanto a la necesidad
de planificación familiar sigue siendo
muy alta las muertes por aborto inseguro
siguen siendo considerables así que es
muy importante que sigamos dando
prioridad a los temas de derechos
sexuales y reproductivos y que
garanticemos el acceso al aborto en esta
parte del planeta en áfrica sin acceso a
bostjan on the spot of the planet in
africa
y actualmente hay algún país en el que
se esté debatiendo el derecho al aborto
en el que está a punto de aprobarse
leyes para flexibilizar la legislación
y por supuesto creo que es uno de los
grandes acontecimientos a lo largo del
tiempo en el que cuando un país como
eeuu está retrocediendo y dando pasos
hacia atrás en términos de derechos
sexuales y reproductivos y de derechos
de las mujeres con sus países de áfrica
se están moviendo en la dirección
correcta para proteger y garantizar el
acceso a estos derechos podemos verlo en
benin en kenia y también en sierra leona
ingenia anuncio inicial y 1976 en clic
de los mets donde recientemente los
gobiernos han respaldado un proyecto de
ley para ampliar el acceso al aborto más
allá de sólo salvar la vida de una mujer
y que ahora verdaderamente retroceder
estas leyes de la época colonial que han
frenado a las mujeres en el pasado
en beni a finales del año pasado el
parlamento respaldó un proyecto de ley
sobre los derechos sexuales
y vos que ha ampliado el acceso a la
atención del aborto en kenia el tribunal
superior de justicia de la ciudad de
malindi ha afirmado recientemente que la
atención al aborto debe ser protegida
por la constitución y que la detención
de las personas que buscan un aborto
pero también de los proveedores que
facilitan el acceso al aborto es
inconstitucional e ilegal
así que estamos viendo estos fuertes
avances en el continente africano
mientras que en paralelo el tribunal
supremo de eeuu por ejemplo ha tomado
una decisión muy importante en la
dirección opuesta
gracias malas por haber estado con
nosotros del 12 al 17 de septiembre el
cine africano será celebrado en la
ciudad colombiana de quibdó donde la
mayoría de la población es
afrodescendiente en su cuarta edición
esta muestra pretende conectar lo mejor
del cine africano idea de la espora a la
llamada pequeña áfrica enclavada en el
pacífico colombiano front 24 asistió a
la presentación del evento y pudo hablar
con su presidente el cineasta wilfried
massamba quien nos presentó el festival
escuchemos
el kit de áfrica team festival es la
cuarta edición la cuarta edición que
estamos haciendo este año desde el 12 al
17 de septiembre ahí en presencia de la
entidad de manera virtual en la
plataforma brunet puntocom y es un
festival afro
afro jazz público africano a floyd
explicó donde queríamos crear puente
entre áfrica y la diáspora africano pero
haya basado aquí en bogotá y
particularmente en quibdó es la idea es
que este puente para mostrar para traer
director africano afrodescendiente y
afro colombianos para encontrarse en
este espacio de encuentro que
queríamos crear entre este director es
entre estas jazz por africanos áreas del
mundo pero basado aquí en egipto el
cineasta también nos comentó la
importancia del séptimo arte para crear
puentes entre colombia y el continente
así como la importancia de mostrar otra
áfrica del mundo
la idea ahorita es mostrar este áfrica
cual es áfrica nuestra herencia que que
empezó desde áfrica hasta las américas
hasta colombia donde estoy ahorita donde
estoy trabajando creando este este
festival muestra este áfrica contó por
ello que no tenemos el hábito de ver en
los medios de comunicación mostrar una
áfrica
con todas sus riquezas de áfrica con
estos jóvenes de áfrica
multiculturales este áfrica que está
conectando el mundo
así despedimos la edición de esta semana
gracias por acompañarnos y la
información continúa en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]